so since I have a little extra time with
you I'm gonna ask you the most important
thing up front did you watch the game of
Thrones finale and what did you think no
I have not seen it so don't tell me
anything because I was traveling from
Russia so we missed it right I have it
and I'm gonna watch it tonight but I
don't want anybody I'm not reading any
of the coverage of it
Sophie walked up and made a declaration
I had to put my fingers in my ears I
don't want to hear it I want to watch
the last episode it's funny James had an
opinion James clearly watched it at some
point but anyway huh so jumping into
getting to talk to you so Simon has been
very involved in the x-men franchise for
so long and he's been a producer and
he's you know what I mean so talk a
little bit about the real what you were
tasked with that because you know Simon
I'm sure is you know I guess I'm just
you could talk a little bit about how
you guys work together and how you know
if that makes any sense sure um you know
Simon and I've worked together in
different capacities going back to x3 so
our relationship is pretty long-standing
and obviously produced all these films
together and it's a it's an effortless
partnership with Simon it just it's he's
incredibly collaborative we've sort of
been solving these problems and
challenges together forever so the
transition to him being director was
pretty organic both because he's so
intimately familiar he's not you know
kind of a writer transitioning from
writing to directing he's a writer who
was a hands-on producer at the same time
on set all the time transitioning
directing so in some ways was pretty
easy and the challenge for me was simply
trying to make sure he had all the tools
he needed to succeed you know which was
getting the right department heads
getting the right you know the right
budget obviously getting the support
from the studio but just serving up all
the ingredients that would allow him to
shine but I I have to say it was pretty
easy and he he transitioned into that
role you know in some ways I found him
more at home in the director's chair
than I did in the writer producers chair
I think it was harder for him to be
writer producer and and be detached from
a lot of the decisions that were
actually being made by the director then
then it was for him to sit in the
director's chair
yeah he didn't crash the Ferrari right
you did not he really didn't he did not
the thing about this film is you guys
together put together this all-star team
behind the scenes who was the person
that was the toughest to land in terms
of whether it be Hans Zimmer or whether
it be your DP you know you would again
an all-star team the one the one that
was the most elusive to me was Hans that
was the one that when when Simon first
said look I want to try to go get Hans
quietly I thought there's no way there's
no way because he'd gone on the record
saying was going to do another comic
book movie neither of us had worked I
hadn't worked for them in a very long
time
Simon hadn't either although Simon is a
huge fan right it's written all this
green place to the tones of scores so
that seemed really beyond our reach and
it was just good fortune that that Hans
was coming through Montreal and was
playing one of his concerts so we all
went to see him play and had a meeting
with him afterwards and and he and Simon
really hit it off and then if we got
talking about the film and he sort of
understood the ambition to try to do
something more grounded in emotional
that really appealed to Hans so I would
say of everybody that was probably our
biggest gap I'm very curious I'm sure
you guys it was a very complicated
process I'm sure to design exactly how
dark Phoenix was gonna look so if he's
makeup how the fire you know all that
stuff so yeah talk a little bit about
the behind the scenes on how you decided
on the final look did it almost do
something completely different yeah it
went through a lot of iterations you
know early on it was much more fire
based and much more kind of in keeping
with what we've seen from the comics but
as as the the line we were trying to
walk is we didn't want any of the
effects or the expression of her Phoenix
power to diminish her ability to perform
as an actress so we had to find a subtle
expression for it and that became the
cracks it became you know for those who
noticed the hair which is an animation
it's almost an underwater effect so you
feel something unnatural is happening
but it's still Sophie that's performing
and then as the power progresses that
the decision was and the feeling was
we've got
to make you feel more cosmic it has to
feel like it's more than a temporal
element right which fire had a feeling
that that it's it's too temporal it's
too earthbound how do we get something
to reflect something that's more cosmic
and that's really what led us to to the
final effect but it was truly iterative
you know we tried a lot of different
variations and explored a lot of
different feelings and as I think you
know probably the biggest challenge of
the movie was given this grounded tone
how do you integrate that with something
cosmic how do you how does the cosmic
not upstage you know this intimate
family drama and trying to find that
finesse was the most difficult thing in
the film I know there's always deleted
scenes in every movie what deleted
scenes will be on the blu-ray eventually
yeah there's some fun scenes one that
that I really like is a scene that sort
of mimics the confrontation between
Charles and Hank and it's between
Charles and Scott where you see you know
Scott challenged Charles to do something
and Charles is at wit's end and
basically screams back at him I don't
know what to do and you see Charles
undone kind of for the first time and I
loved that scene I know Simon loved that
scene at the end of the day we felt like
we didn't really we didn't really need
it it was sort of it was sort of a
repeat of ideas we'd already expressed
and so those tend to be scenes you pull
out but it's a scene I love and then
there are a lot of you know connected
tissue seems there's some scenes that
are that are residual from from having
shifted our ending to being much more
grounded and less supernatural on its
base that that we will have in the DVDs
well that's the other thing I wanted to
know is I I heard that you had a
different ending originally and I'm
curious with something like that do you
get to put that on the blu-ray like the
alt ending or is it something that you
know what I mean if there's a different
version if if we had a completed version
of it we would have put it on the
blu-ray but we actually change direction
while we were shooting so not everything
that went with that was finished and
and it was really driven mostly by
realizing we wanted to ground the movie
and make the movie live within these
characters and those issues so this goes
back to that notion of how do you
balance the cosmic and the so we just
needed an ending that better served Jean
and her relationship to Charles and the
family that also included Jessica
Chastain and her characters wants so
pretty tricky balance in the end and I
think it required that adjustment but
and then we didn't we didn't finish all
those other pieces there we go on that
note again Congrats on the movie thanks
bud and watch Game of Thrones tonight
yes thank you for real thanks to
everyone watch it soon